[Music]
[Music]
it's really great to know that all the
effort we put in has been appreciated by
more than two hundred thousand people
all around the world so it's a great
achievement feels really good
Wow two hundred thousand subscribers I
still cannot really believe that that's
true
especially because of the story of how
we got here right so I remember
distinctly the first day when we decided
we were gonna start with YouTube team
and you'll be blundered our way into
building videos and you know what users
like you basically said this is not good
enough and engagement was poor and you
know we tried a few things the
experiment and we hired good people and
you know in less than a year from that
day then we felt like this is such a
mountain to climb there are two hundred
thousand subscribers so Wow thank you
thank you from the deepest of our hearts
I think we would never have been able to
make it here without your support so
thank you I'm so proud that we've
reached this 200 thousand subscriber
milestone these are professionals around
the world who realize if they're trying
to figure out the digital competencies
and get those skills they need to drive
your career forward and help their
companies we are a great resource I'm
really excited to share that it of
course more than 200,000 plus
subscribers on our YouTube channel in a
very short period of time how do you
tube channel is a great source for a lot
of free content on new modules kills
200,000 subscribers that's amazing I you
know I get excited when I have a roomful
of 15-20 people that I'm talking to copy
that we have activities we want to get
subscribers and I hoped I'd die China
make the same progress and we need no
next milestone that year
it's a pleasure to be a part of YouTube
team and I'm so happy that I'm also
being a good contributor for this 200k
Club I am very happy that you took him
as a choose 200k subscribers you're
looking forward to greater success I
feel it's really fantastic to know that
you know
the videos are touching 200,000 people
and it's helping them grow and develop
in their careers it feels so great
that's giving 200k subscribers not every
channel can achieve this milestone
easily it's pleasure to be a part of the
team you know which is helping the
people upscaling themselves in this
digital space such an amazing support
from all you guys it's been a pleasure
working here at simply nan and to clear
to contain for the amazing subscribers
like you most challenging part for my
site was to understand the audience on
you know make the right kind of content
so that it reaches people the way they
want it the most challenging aspect of
my work is to create content that is
engaging and meaningful to a global
audience both for professionals and
beginners who want to rescale and
upscale themselves but YouTube team I
have the opportunity to create something
new every day so overall it's a very
nice experience we want to create
content for a viewer that sells really
accurate and fun at the same time for
them so the most exciting part about our
usual journey is creating the content
itself because of the new technologies
that we cover and and they're things
that may even be learned by creating
that content the YouTube team is a very
creative team to be a part of the
YouTube team is really inspiring for me
and the learning journey never ends here
at Santino I follow a lot like music
magic football cricket and if it comes
to education is always simply not going
by the momentum we are hopeful to reach
find out K subscribers in 6 months and 1
million in a year the idea was always
that simply learn is here to change
people's lives right that is the common
thread that runs across this company and
if you think about of courses not
everybody really assure that you want to
buy an expensive course and get your
training right and it's pretty
complicated so we thought look before
you jump in and just buy a course or
commit to yourself to something why not
provide you something to look at get a
good sense of what you could do with
your career what these technologies
really mean for you over these how you
can get some digital skills for free
right
I started simply learn 10 years back as
a blog to share my own learning
and this YouTube channel is a
continuation of the same belief of
giving back to the society I encourage
all of you to make use of this freebie
so share with your friends family and
connect and help them get started and
fast working the career in the newest
emerging digital skills
congratulations simply learn on 200,000
subscribers and it's my pleasure to
bring you these webinars and to
introduce you to your subject matter
experts that give you the skills to help
advance your careers whether it's your
present job or the one that you dream
about if you are a subscriber to this
you know kudos you've already taken the
first step to moving forward and having
a continual flow of Education in being
in the know whether you're at the
beginning level or your very advanced
and you're already like a man admin even
system admins who've been doing it for
years they suddenly have a Hadoop file
system and the boss comes up and says
hey I want to upgrade to version 3 which
has you know that our backup systems
they have to go get educated in there so
in all levels the online learning system
keep it up keep subscribing to our video
feed keep evolving your own network of
learning and growth personally makes me
feel good it's gratifying that so many
people fine
videos interesting and the thing I would
have to say to the people watching them
is continue to put their comments into
the comment box below the video to me
that just makes it easier for us to
understand what your needs are what you
like about the videos but you don't like
about the videos I think in balloons
YouTube channel is an amazing way for
people to take the first few steps into
learning all of the digital technologies
which are becoming really popular and
the team has done an amazing job and
coming up with really good videos which
cover right from the basics all the way
to a fairly in-depth coverage of the
topic so kudos to the whole team
reaching two hundred thousand YouTube
subscribers is such an exciting
milestone for us because it means that
our users enjoy the content as much as
we do expert webinars live streams
tutorials so if you haven't already what
are you waiting for hit the subscribe
button and help us reach 300,000
subscribers
[Music]
as to all the 200,000 subscribers for
making this dude is so incredible and
complete we try to help you all who take
that next step in your career by
creating false and other new
technologies making content that is very
easy to understand the floor of example
is an tactical keep flowing in your
amazing comments some of my favorites
being how can I like with no that one's
actually I to data science for overall
no and never came close to such clear
concise and broad it finishes you might
need I am you to as your and the fun to
make sense of it but could figure it out
you cleared up everything for me these
are amazing
next up is how community subscribers so
if you walk in this video on having
subscribe subscribe now look that yes we
are again or to a thousand people get
like to connect so so one more time
wait then how many smiley